SPEAKER: Natural
Language API can
be used to perform sentiment,
entity, and syntax analysis
on text.
Let's just see how to
use Natural Language
API with C Shell.
First, make sure the API
is enabled in your project
and the service icon
exists to make API calls.
Both are explained in the
code lab in the video notes.
In Cloud Shell, let's create a
simple .net console app and add
Natural Language API Nougat
package to the project.
Open the Code Editor and
navigate to program.cs.
We will perform sentiment
analysis on a piece of text.
Reference Natural
Language API library.
Create language service client.
Call analyze
sentiment on the text.
Get the sentiment, and
finally, print the results.
Let's run the app.
There you go.
You just performed
sentiment analysis
using Natural Language API.